hey everyone this is Kim from the chess
website calm today we're in round 13 of
our coverage of the 2018 Canada's
tournament with 14 total rounds this is
coming down to the very end Fabiano
Caruana LED for most of the tournaments
and then Sergei cardiac in who won this
thing two years ago came storming back
and beats Caruana in the last round to
go
tied with Caruana on the same number of
points but he does have the tiebreaker
which is going to be how you did against
that individual you're tied with so if
they stay at the same points cardiac him
will be victorious cardiac Ian's in
round 13 did tie his game so we're gonna
be looking at Fabiano Cara Juana with
the white pieces against Levon Aronian
with the black pieces Cara wanna really
needs to get this victory he has the
black pieces tomorrow for the last and
final round so if he does not get a
victory here he's gonna have to have a
miracle tomorrow his opponent one of the
strongest players in the world but not
having the tournament that Aronian would
like to he is in last place and looking
for something so we'll go ahead and get
started a lot on the line for this
particular game starts out with pawn to
e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 agreeance
who the Rye Lopez Bishop here to b5 pawn
to a6 Bishop back to a4 Knight to f6
castle on the King side pretty much the
common line that we're used to seeing
lately bishop here eise Evan rook to e1
upon to b5 pushing the bishop back here
to be three and after castle on the
kingside pawn to d3 pawn d6
and then Bishop to d2 and this is not
the most common line that we see this is
starting to get into the Marshall attack
from white many times you'll see pawn to
c3 right away
Bishop to c2 is a move that we actually
solved from Alexander Glueck last round
when he played Levon Aronian good ishik
had the white pieces the Longborough
knee and play the black pieces he has to
play back-to-back rounds as the black
pieces
this same opening now the one thing that
you'll notice is they had a day off
yesterday so after round 12
Fabiano as you can guess he studied
Levon Aronian gameplay just to see how
he would approach not only all the games
but particularly this variation as well
a wall they did draw that game in the
last round
Fabiano spent the full day off looking
and said he really liked to this bishop
here to d2 move so that's what he played
in the game bishop down here to g4 in
the previous game Levon Aronian played
King here to h8 against kaduche cook but
did some additional studying and the
computers recommended that he played
Bishop to g4 so that's exactly what he
did
now pawn to c3 and this is more of the
anti a Marshall attack pawn here to d5
and Caruana is not looking to take this
pawn in the center he has the option
could always do that but that's not what
he's looking to do here many times white
will avoid that in the center just
because it gives black a strong attack
White's not looking to give black a
strong attack in this game so pond h3
forcing the bishop to come back here and
then Queen to e2 if you purist you know
what this would look like I'll go over
some variations after Queen to e2 I
maybe rook to b8 and then Bishop to g5
but if we were to see the pawn take here
on d5 the knight takes on d5 pawn up
here to g4 forcing the bishop come to
back to g6 now the Knight to e5 it is
being protected by the Queen and the
rook here maybe the the Knight takes
Queen takes pawn down here to c6 Bishop
captures and then doesn't really matter
where it goes from here why could decide
just to come up say yeah you could take
my queen I can take your Queen as well
but at the end of the day this is gonna
be pretty interesting from blacks point
of view he has the bishop pair here and
you know this is gonna be pretty fine
for black not something that white wants
to get into with a black having very
very good development as far as his
bishops his night here on Abby
one's not doing anything all of the
major pieces for black are very involved
into the game so as many players do we
see Fabiano decides to go ahead and not
take this material instead gets his dark
square Bishop involved into the game
Bishop up here to g5 and then we see
levana and say yeah I'll go ahead and
take that pawn so pawn takes on e4 pawn
recaptures pawn here to h6 forcing the
bishop to come back not really a good
place for this bishop besides c1 you
don't want to bring it back here to f5
who would just get or f4 be be captured
here and then each three is just
blocking off the Queen and then d2 it's
blocking off the night here on b1 so
comes back here to c1 we are 15 moves in
and at the the press game afterwards
they were asking about his preparation
for this particular opening because he
really hasn't played this before and
Fabiano said that he memorized the first
15 moves for this variation he didn't
know exactly where his opponent was
gonna go with the bishop down here to g4
earlier instead of the King to h8 which
Aronian played in in the last round but
he was prepared for it and up into this
point really hasn't spent much time on
the clock knowing that this is a great
position for what he's trying to do and
it was all memorized so we go in from
the no longer in the the memorized book
lines and black continues with Bishop
back here to g6 now why it's gonna get
his other night involved into the game
night here to d2 and it's not gonna be
coming here to c4 or affords you can
imagine so the next place is going to be
f1 because there's no bishop that's
gonna come down here and exchange off
with this night so Knight down here to
f1 and has a few options could always
come up here to e3 could come here to g3
could even come over here to h2 and then
maneuver to g4 if white wanted to Knight
to h5 Knight here to f1 and then Bishop
down here to c5 this is really great
square for Aronian as he is controlling
these dark squares and it does block off
but I can't come to g3 is Fabi out of my
appointed - that would just be disaster
Knight say
and the pond can take is being pinned
down by this bishop here to the king so
that would be a huge mistake so instead
we see pawn to g3 which is an
interesting approach on how White's
gonna get safety for is king because now
we can just push forward with King here
to g2 we see the black beside yeah I'll
go into a similar type move and play
King here to h7 and not to have my keen
exposed back here on the eighth-ranked
or being pinned down by the bishop here
on b3 because both of these bishops are
doing a good job of attacking these very
very critical squares here on f7 as well
as f2 so King up here to g2 as we talked
about Queens to e7 Bishop down here to
see to adding another layer of
protection on this pawn on e4 we're
cover here to add e8 and then pawn up
here to b4 and there's a lot of options
that white has here as far as how he's
gonna continue I recommend not playing
something like d1 if you want to counter
attack in the center this is not how you
do it because after the rook takes
Bishop takes then just rook over here to
d8 both of these bishops are not
involved into the action the Brooke here
on d8 is controlling the long file so
not something you want to do right away
but if you look at some of the other
options you have Knight - III this says
block off the bishop from attacking down
here you also have something like Bishop
to e3 this is a move that I would be
looking at personally because it says
hey if you want to take that's fine I'll
recapture with my knight here this is
the square I want to bring my knight to
get it very involved into the center I
bring in it to any of these outpost
right here and I no longer have to worry
about you're very very aggressive Bishop
up here on c5 now Fabiano did choose the
better of all the options and that is to
play pawn to b4 and start attacking on
the Queen side so kudos for him as you
could imagine if you wanna best players
in the world did find that the best move
as the many of the top GM commentators
were going through and said yes a b4 is
the best line so Bishop comes back to b6
pond up here to a for continuing the
attack here Knight to f6 just trying to
get a centralized wasn't doing much here
on h5 all things considered just trying
to reap
at some point that's exactly what he
does night here to h4 attacking the
bishop queen down here to e6 Bishop to
d3 wants to add even more attackers for
this square here on b5 now black plays
Bishop to h5 not looking to give up the
bishop right away it attacks the Queen
pawn up here to g4 says I'll block that
with my pawn here and the Maharani and
says okay I'll take that well let's
let's go all out I'm in last place in
the tournament who cares I'll just try
to go crazy Bishop takes on g4 and so we
start to see some crazy computation from
both sides pawn takes here on g4 Knight
takes on g4 and that up here to f5 was
attacking the bishop but since is not
doing that does want to bring it to this
outpost here on f5 and then the knight
takes on f2 still being protected by the
bishop on here on b6 oh great little
square the King can't take as you can
see that's being protecting the Queen
that would just be completely terrible
so the bishop comes back here to see to
says yes I don't want to lose my bishop
here that's the one thing I have going
for me if I'm gonna give up a lot of my
pawns and I'm gonna be stuck with mostly
minor pieces I want those minor pieces
to work well together
so decides to go ahead and play bishop
back here to see to hold on to the
bishops pawn to g6 as we usually see
here kicking back the Knights Knight
comes up here to e3 and this is a great
fine because there's a few options that
white can continue with this he
recognizes that this pawn is gonna fall
he wants to take this Knight right here
and so there's a couple ways to block
this off one is with the knight to e3
what happens here though is Knight to h3
the Queen is protecting it maybe Knight
up here to d5 attacking the bishop
Knight down here to g1 attacking the
Queen Queen to d3 it's just kind of
annoying still dealing with this bishop
here on b6 didn't really block it off as
at all
and the knight here on G 1 is still
hanging out now if we come back and say
okay what if we play Knight to e3 that's
exactly what we do in the game now if
the pawn takes here on f5 then the King
can just take here Fabiano did decide to
go ahead and take with his pawn here on
f5 first knowing that he can take this
Knight if he wants to but decided first
to go ahead and take that pawn if he
takes with this King you know I think
this completely fine key takes F to pawn
down here to f4 rook over here to h1
maybe rook to these six
I think this stops a lot of the threats
that black could have but Fabiana looked
at and said I just don't even want to
have to to deal with that now I have
this pawn in this Bishop still attacking
this long dark diagonal so in the game
he decides to go ahead and first take
pawn takes on f5 and then after the
Queen comes over here since it is being
attacked now the Queen takes on f2 no it
doesn't even have his King on that long
dark diagonal and from here pawn to e4
and Levon Aronian after the match was
asked about this position while he has
especially after E for he's in a
tremendously bad position one of his
friends and colleagues that goes over
the matches with him actually pointed
out that he had the option of Knight
taking here on before and after the pawn
takes then the rook down here on d4 and
as you analyze this position which they
did for a long time in the game if
you're watching Peter Svidler he was
going over these positions
black is actually doing pretty well here
and he's controlling a lot of the center
of the board he can give this other rook
involved into the game this would be
fine for black both Levon Aronian and
Fabiano bow said they missed the fact
that the knight could take here and then
bring the rook down here this would have
been a fantastic play by Levon Aronian
that's not what he played in the game
instead played pawn to e4 doesn't really
help his position too much rook over to
h1 really starting a strong attack on
the King side of the board rook to these
six bishop takes on e4
so now
has a very strong attacking bishop he
also has this rook over here can swing
his other rook this bishop here on a c-1
as soon as this knight gets activated at
some point once the queen is no longer
pinned down can start to attack this h6
Square as well
rook to GA check King down here to f1
getting safety Knight to e5 a queen up a
to f6 or f4 also attacking the square
here on h6 pawn c6 that's not doing
anything ahead all whole pawn takes on
b5 rook down to g5 trying to just hold
on the King side of the board but also
just giving up a ton of material on the
Queen side so now we have a passed pawn
here on a6 Queen back here to d8 says
I'll try to stop some of that but it
also just opens up the door for more
attacking on the King sided board punt
up here to f6 Knight to g6 and then the
rook takes on h6 and at this point Levon
Aronian said yeah I will go ahead and
resign the estimate after the match if
he was disappointed that he didn't find
that Knight taking here on b4 and he
said honestly I just don't even care is
you can imagine someone saying that they
just have not had a good tournament seem
like every single round he has has lost
started started not out not too bad and
then just went completely south
sometimes people ask how would this game
continue if you were to take with his
King Queen down here to h2 no real good
way to stop this this pawn here on f6 is
doing a lot of work since the King can't
retreat back there so maybe rook to h5
Knight to f5 forcing the King to move
back here since the bishop here on c1 is
now attacking as we mentioned earlier
this entire dark diagonal so now the
rooks gonna fall things just get really
really bad from here Knight up here to
e7 this is a great outpost check you can
see how bad things get from here so at
the end of day Levon Aronian said I will
resign and Fabiano he is now in the lead
going into the last round tomorrow
he had it two years ago had an
opportunity to win
the whole thing and did not slipped away
from him he will be looking to come
tomorrow and have a strong performance
if he wins then he is the winner if he
draws then he will be looking for
certainly a county yakin to draw as well
because car yakin could win car yakin
has the white pieces and his game if he
gets the win here and they are tied
remember Kuryakin will get the victory
will win back-to-backs candidate
back-to-back candidate tournament so
it's gonna be a huge day tomorrow be
looking for some analysis but if you do
want spoilers from that you can watch
some live action throughout different
sites so I'll be checking that out life
but we'll be doing another video as well
as you can imagine from around 14 so
thank you guys for following along it
has been a fantastic tournament I'm
curious to see who's gonna win and see
how they will fare against a Magnus
Carlsen later in the year see you guys
in round 14